all right this I think you're going to
love Mike pillow is back and now he's
praying for me and he seems to have no
memory that we did a beautiful extensive
interview on the program just like I
don't know a year ago or something like
that uh so let's kind of go back to the
beginning some of you may remember
there's this guy Mike Lindell he's the
CEO and founder of my pillow he showed
up with national a kind of presence at
the beginning of the pandemic Donald
Trump brought him to the White House and
he said oh we're going to make masks or
we're going to make all these different
things and he believed Donald Trump was
selected by God and is generally kind of
a wacky guy then Mike pillow as we know
know him or just pillow was rocketed to
fame not necessarily stardom but I guess
Fame notoriety maybe is a better word in
fighting for the overturning of the 2020
presidential election in just about
every state he claims Trump won like
California you know wacky wacky stuff
and at a certain point I interviewed him
and the interview was super interesting
I mean I don't know that we really work
in convinced that indeed Trump won but
it was interesting to hear from Mike
pillow and the interview did very well
on our Channel
a few weeks ago the real Mike pillow
showed up on our Facebook page and
started making all sorts of allegations
and accusations against me and we went
back to him and we said Hey listen we'd
love to have you back on the program and
so far it hasn't happened well over the
weekend he showed up again in the
comments of our YouTube channel there
was a post just like a funny little post
about the bonus show it's a picture of
me with my baby daughter and I'm having
one of my globally famous and much
despised cappuccinos and it's just fun
that's all it is and the real Mike
Lindell verified account shows up and
says praying for you David you don't
know me but you sure enjoy attacking me
would love to have you on my show well
permission granted sir I would love to
be on the Mike pillow show we are trying
to get him back on on our program to get
the latest updates about you know the
machines and all of this different stuff
we're doing a class
lawsuit again all machine
for our countries have now been taken by
the machines exactly I would love to
have them back on he his his people
don't seem to be allowing him to do it
or at least not really telling him I
don't know he seems eager but they don't
and I would love to be on his program
and one of the funniest things is he
seems to genuinely have no recollection
of the fact that we do know each other
we have each other's numbers he's been
on the program we talked on the show we
talked off the show I know he's a busy
guy but you would think with the amount
of time he's spending on my Facebook
page he would have some memory of the
fact that we did a an interview and
Haley actually pointed out to him you've
literally been a guest on his show
within the last year and that is
absolutely true so pillow increasingly
spending time on my Facebook page which
in a way I love and I'm flattered and
the funniest thing about this this is
like a little behind the scenes thing
um producer Pat not long ago was trying
to get the interview booked with pillow
after he made these comments there's no
doubt that it's the real mic pillow okay
when you click it goes to his verified
page with a hundred and fifty thousand
followers this is pillow's real Facebook
account his staff said to Pat we very
much doubt that he's been commenting on
David's Facebook videos they it they
don't seem to be willing to either
accept it or look into it but it's
pillow and he's welcome on the show and
I would love to be on his show one of
the most interesting and depraved
characters of this entire Global
nightmare that has been Mega trumpism I
have a really tough time finding dress
shirts I like they're either
uncomfortable or they're tight or
they're loose or hot or itchy and that's
why it's been so great to discover the
commuter shirts made by our fantastic
sponsor Rhone rhone's commuter shirt is
a reinvention of the men's dress shirt
it's the most comfortable dress shirt
I've worn Roan's comfortable four-way
stretch fabric provides the
breathability and the flexibility that
leaves you free to enjoy what life
throws your way could be a long day at
work could be brunch with the family
you're just going to be comfortable and
that's so important with rhones wrinkle
release technology the wrinkles
disappear as you stretch and wear the
shirt which is very convenient and Rhone
is 100 percent machine washable so you
can skip the dry cleaning altogether
I've had a great experience with Rhone
the shirts are appropriate if you want
to look nice or somewhat formal
I rarely need to and they're just as
good as a comfortable t-shirt when you
want to relax or just move around in it
go to rhone.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 20 off the most
comfortable shirt you'll ever own the
link is down below